Eric Griffin is here you knew him
previously from workaholics now from I'm
dying up here oh do you know mark
Normand how you doing buddy I'm like way
over you eating it smells delicious no
it's not yeah you're eating a brain it
doesn't look good it smells good yeah
right right you bought it oh wow such a
white thing to do you know putting
ketchup on it just on everything right
right the terrorists really want to get
us that's what they should do go to the
ketchup factory I just destroy it order
no you just put the poison in the
ketchup that's cyanide in the ketchup
yeah security get the ketchup place no
July weekend I'll be nine Americans left
you get the cancer and we're out why am
I telling them on our secrets you know
yeah no you're right this isn't gonna
turn out well how was Jim's show I I the
the the Showtime I'm dying up here I
haven't seen it but it's about what
about stand up in the 70s right yeah
yeah yeah it's all about the seventies
is what it is it's only loosely based
off the book I'm dying up here it's
probably more about Jim's own personal
stories you know it's great he took us
to dinner season one before we started
and he was telling all these great
stories about Kinnison and and and his
himself like how when he got to LA he
lived in a closet you know so that's why
some of the characters live in a closet
when he first got to LA from Boston you
know and so it's just it's just a
fascinating time to look at that you
know all these Giants of comedy that we
know now the people that we've been
loving for 20 30 years that they started
at this in this era so that's what we're
trying to convey in the show do you like
that you get to do a lot of stand-up on
it because they know that's the worst
they don't like it no no no dude stand
up first of all there's extras and you
got to get all these angles
that's my standup right you know it's
never been able to be captured properly
it never reads it's never we never read
it's garbanzo so it's like it's really
about the people like when we get away
from this so this season they have like
just a couple of hits and then you can
see it's funny because like al Madrigal
you guys know al yeah yeah Alys
hilarious and these little mall
city has you you don't want to see a
long set by an actor you know in this in
this you know clinical environment
basically doing it in front of extras is
weird too I've done that before and then
all of a sudden they think that they
they have to like do something audience
like and they I've done it whether it
was somebody groaning in the audience oh
are you groaning during a taping you
[ __ ] dummy trying to add me like dude
don't even get me started like then like
if you watch extras after a while it
becomes a thing where it's like they
have to be like you know right they have
to like put your hands in the air just
they're not following what's going on
because they think the director is gonna
be watching like I believe that laughs
that's a story many times when I'm when
I was doing it I'd be on stage a bit hey
guys just relax well you don't want to
be and then I would like in between
takes
I'm like just doing a real like yeah I'm
doing crowd work yeah I'm warming up for
myself
yeah and then it's time for them then
they still get back into that robotic
you know cuz you got to relax them it's
heart I've done a bunch of different
times and you got to relax them a little
bit because it's really hard to look
like you're relaxed and laughing and
having a good time when you've heard of
joke six time i Scott Caan all right we
got a lighting issue and then you got to
do the same jokes as a stand-up it's the
most unnatural thing totally is to do
the same joke twice and for the same
people oh yeah that part of its to worse
but then that's what I getting paid
though so like you know Kate you should
that's right [ __ ] Chara I feel like
you have to do it more than most though
because your character is the host so
often yeah you end up like you end up
getting a load [ __ ] from stand-up money
even a headliner on my own show I know
but it's um it's a very rewarding
experience because if you know me from
workaholics it's like I'm just weird you
know outrageous character then I had to
go to this thing and have to like you
know be like a dramatic actor and it's
like it's very rewarding I really
enjoyed the experience and um you know
something I always have where'd you come
up stand up lies Oh
in LA you know I was born and raised in
LA if you could believe that and I just
you know started to know just doing open
mics you know I remember remember
remember that guy Arie he he had the
Friars Club going on
yes at the la version yes I remember
I've got Steven Seagal there one night
was Jason Alexander was playing poker in
the back and being loud while I was on
stage you were such a weird weird tell
me shut the [ __ ] up somebody tell George
to shut up yeah that was a fun game that
la it was by like little Santa Monica or
something Santa Monica Boulevard yeah
that closed right yes I think so that's
been closed but yeah but sorry I had to
go into the LA scene it was hard because
I didn't know I don't have any mentors I
don't nobody told me anything you know
and I just had I had to do contests and
things like that just to get out of it
and then go out of town you know I
remember I won a contest and I got to
open for what's-his-name which one was
that I'm trying to think I've had so
many damn contest
Bill Cosby I'm surprised he's still
alive by the way but anyway we were just
talking about that I'm surprised he
hasn't Joe Paterno out yeah we were
thinking that his strategy was that he
would try to get this thing pushed and
pushed hoping that he would just die and
then when he didn't die and the
sentencing is coming up he's like what
happened what he was about to go on tour
yeah it's true I go on tour still
selling more tickets to me it's 80 rapes
and he's like popular humiliate you know
what yes you know what you have to do
Eric no but yeah yeah Paterno had the
best exit it really did [ __ ] all the
kids is bachina amazing that dude
[ __ ] so good is that good I mean
credible everything but you know has
been doing for HBO is amazing it's dark
yes he's just finding a new new thing
because he was like such a cartoon of
himself was for a long time it was
almost like they said like they was they
were casting a Pacino type right and he
would come in and they were like but
this is a Pacino enough you know then
HBO goes how about Phil Spector
Kevorkian and Joe Paterno who can do
that not
right nobody does it better than Pacino
but anyway I remember I did a one-car it
was Dave Attell I open oh yeah I won
this contest in northern whatever and
then I hope you open for him and then
without the kind of things I did to get
myself going you know so weird I had to
be a security that day that night why
well you know at the time he was a
little saucy oh yeah yeah you know so we
were walking in this little town you
know people are just coming up to him oh
yeah yeah you know I'm just I'm a big
guy one of my wait a minute I'm not I'm
getting paid for this did you take that
roll on just because you're a good guy
or would you like I did kind of felt
like he's such an unassuming guy
sometimes so he just was like all these
people are surrounding him and so I said
okay everybody back up you know but
people waited an hour to let just talk
to him I did show I know I signed some
titties you know we did yeah just
because he you know they said you too
and I was like wow this is great
is there anything better than signing at
it yeah feel like you've made it in show
business so you sign a breast signing at
it and then when you get off the plane
and there's a guy with your name on a
sign those are the two things you go I
made it what a picture of you that they
want you to sign with that blue marker
cuz they're gonna sell it when you're
walking through an airport I never have
a lot of them I'll have maybe two or
three right but they could you sign this
and I'm well I love that I know if you
can make money off this dog [ __ ] knock
yourself out funny cuz like real
celebrities hate it that's like the one
they're like you know what this is a
great life but the airport guys they
just drive me crazy I don't know I got
off a plane recently and I didn't know
how they knew I was gonna be where I was
yeah that scared the [ __ ] out of me I've
talked to wrestlers about this you have
a real problem with the airport like the
wrestling fans show up to every airport
they go to and it got so bad they were
calling the flight they were calling the
airline saying what time is this flight
getting in figuring out okay well if the
show ends at this time and they have a
day off tomorrow they'll be on that
flight Wow what time is the flight and
then they would buy the cheapest airline
ticket available so they could get into
the gate yeah when they got off weren't
even waiting for baggage claim like
we're meeting people at the gate and
being like we signed this smart
yeah you see what it from donkey in this
day and age our autographs are they seem
so meaningless yes but I don't how many
sakes yeah the only reason why you had
autographs before is because you didn't
have instant pictures and but people
people ask me that sometimes hey can you
sign this and I go why don't we take a
picture it seems to be more valuable and
more proof it's crazy right it's crazy
like what who cares about my squiggle
yeah I'll get them on a picture of me in
the person sure Wednesday roger daltrey
it now he's Roger he's in he's in the
build August today I had a picture like
I should get that sign yeah I don't know
I
yes you should I don't know us of course
but if it's a picture you guys you'll
get it frame there's a signature he's in
the photo but yeah when it's just like
glossy eight-by-tens
yeah or or the ticket to your show you
know and I sorta get it but at the same
time I'm like why don't we just you know
let's just take a picture yeah I have a
whole picture rules too when I take
pictures at shows you know I had to tell
people rule number one I have your
[ __ ] camera ready yeah okay
rule number two don't count I'm ready
okay one I'm smiling right yeah yeah
it's like you know we're standing here
like and you're asked that dumb question
are you ready yeah [ __ ] picture don't
we stand like this all the time like
yeah like you know before when they oh
I'm sorry that was on video and you're
like oh good so now you have a video of
me look like a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
nobody's people like you know they come
up to you and they just like I get it
though like I'm not I would never I
never complained about the fans right
and in my level of Fame it's like 1 out
of 40 people right so I could still go
to lunch and things like that and I
kissed it's not a I could imagine being
like Will Smith as well yeah it's
probably a nightmare it's why they they
live this recluse life and they're just
gone you know yeah like Jim Carrey comes
to the set every now and then and you
know or these little press events we
have and I can just tell that I was like
oh you're not a real person anymore
right like he hasn't been a real person
in a while do you see that the Kaufman
documentary with Jim Carrey yeah yeah it
seemed like totally but he was aware of
how not a person he was mmm like what
he's gone through a lot of stuff man
that's yeah but his girl and all that
stuff that happened and they were suing
him yeah
not thinking now that at all is taken
care of and he's gonna be on a TV show
on the Showtime you know and so now he I
think he's like God found his groove I
think once he got on set and once he's
you know I think he's there I wouldn't
even be surprised if he started doing
stand-up again just to try it yeah and
these guys who don't who are really good
he was a really good stand-up oh yeah it
was but any Murphy was a great stander
and he didn't he just did they don't
want anymore why do they have too much
respect for it and there's too much
expectation on them like if anyone or
Jim Carrey walks on instinct people like
Jim Carrey was been not realizing
listened done in eight years he's just
trying to yeah and I'm sure that that's
what it was but wasn't Eddie Murphy at
the SNL reunion battle wasn't it the
most bizarre thing you ever saw in your
life like here we go it's right he's
back and then nothing that guy hasn't
been a normal person and you know thirty
yeah he's been a star since he was 22 21
did you see him while he was on the new
version of ours Arsenio show and he's
being interviewed with sunglasses on
right for like for like four segments
and I just thought weren't said you know
like Arsenio and you have worked
together things on TV is hideous yeah
yeah Brando didn't wear sunglasses on
dick Cavett's stupid at the SNL thing he
just kind of got up and everybody had
done funny stuff and when he got up in
front of the audience he just did a
super serious like yeah Thank You speech
that's it and it was really out of place
but you know what though he probably
didn't feel like being funny because he
has a weird relationship with us to Nell
anyway yeah yes that whole like I think
you know he feels like I think he feels
like they don't remember what he did you
know or he but he got kind of like a
LeBron type attitude though you know I
mean he's got that I'm the greatest of
all time type of thing and it's just
like now alright yeah you know the
reason why I'm doing stand-up is because
of Eddie Murphy so oh I totally get why
he would feel that way and there and SNL
at the time should have been called the
Eddie Murphy show right well he kind of
did save the franchise and that's why
when David Spade did that joke about a
movie called and [ __ ] right you
wouldn't have a job if it wasn't for me
[ __ ] yeah there's two two people that
SNL should think for you know really
helping their show any Murphy in Donald
Trump
yeah I've sent him a gift basket every
week right yeah
Colbert - yeah yeah absolutely SNL
Zaroff
yeah yeah SNL is done for the season I
think cuz otherwise I mean the fact that
Donald Trump goes on Twitter yesterday
and post the photo of him and Kim
Kardashian it's like you're just giving
it to him go getting on their case that
the desk was empty but what you're gonna
have state secrets on the desk in the
room like naturally I'm like what you
know the missile strike it's gonna be
right you don't but in that picture
that's what people are an empty desk how
crazy is it that the Kardashian is
sitting next to in the White House like
it's good most bizarre thing there's all
the levels to it first just a photo of
Trump as the president you're like for
real and then Kim Kardashian's next to
him and then the headline says talking
about prison reform I remember when
Obama first got elected and they had
this video crew kind of following him
and he gets on Air Force One for the
first time they said all right anything
the guy comes over and says mr.
president can I get you anything
it Obama says yeah let me get a
cheeseburger and in my mind I thought
don't do that that's not presidential
like at the time I thought that that was
the most unpresidential thing you could
do is gratis burger on Air Force One so
much fun it must be either cheeseburger
on Air Force now but you don't let the
people see burger you order some a fine
a piece of salmon to get my don't think
you don't think President Trump has
enjoyed any greasy foods on Air Force
One day now the level the levels of
what's like you know unpresidential has
been like so warm tea right right you
think Trump's cleaning staff at the
White House is annoyed because there's
always grease stains on his bedsheets
phone cuz he wipes his fingers off his
bedsheets these sauces and the mustard
just imagine the Tantrums he must throw
it like two o'clock in the morning I
just love that he wants McDonald's at
that hour there's nothing better than
that
Big Mac sauce on his pillowcase the
whole place smells like that the white
trash trailer
[Laughter]
could be a funny sitcom is just like
like just it's just called Air Force One
and it's just like an office comedy
about the staff yeah yeah yeah how do
you get honey at McDonald's smell out of
an area there's two ketchup packets in a
rubber a hundred percent you're a
hundred percent support porn after the
whole scandal I had watched before I use
I knew if stormy Daniels before to
perfect he's one of those heroes I know
the names of the porn people I do I like
to respect who I'm watching you know I
know big comedians I know it's not just
a random joke talent for the porn stars
it's not just you don't just jump to the
punch lines anymore you want to see the
setup in the callback right right then I
go on wiki and is really a true story
that really happen didn't do it she
didn't even want that to come out by the
way storming yeah that's not even her
fault she's forced she's gonna keep her
120,000 you're like I'm done yeah she
was forced to come out cuz you did they
were they were like getting on her name
that's crazy
she doesn't mind people knowing now she
really has taken the ball and run with
it she really has she was like the key
to the city in LA or something she's
trying to run for office
it's just visit first of all by the way
the we can't impeach Trump we have to
beat him and off beat him in an election
because if you impeach him it's gonna
embolden that crazy core and they're
coming sure think of him as a martyr
sure so we what we need is a candidate
that it can legitimately beat him are
you because he's gonna win again
I guess what you need to prepare for all
these liberal [ __ ] out here they like
to complain about things but don't
actually take action right she's gonna
win again and by the way anyone who uh I
don't I don't mind Trump I don't hate
his guts at all but I gotta say anyone
who hates Trump but you get rid of him
you got Mike Pence right and he's Trump
something you could say that's are you
kidding
that's the
Trump was because of my pence I don't
hate that one like that Mike Pence is a
doctor's note or assassin's bullet away
from being the president of the United
States right raise e that's a he would
never ever dream he knows he's a career
politician and he knows that in the in
the climate of this polity of the
politics he would never be able to be
president not in the cards it's not
right which this isn't gonna happen for
me and right so now he's like wow yeah I
actually have a chance he's probably the
one encouraging me eat McDonald's Big
Mac what they say about you
treat yourself they're running you down
in the present bid for you've earned it
treaters it's like a plot of some CBS
show or something you know where like
the vice president like you know he's in
a coup you know I would not be surprised
like he simply is trying to get him in
peace that would be a great show if the
Vice President was trying to give the
president heart disease like if he just
kept slipping him greasy foods or
killing him in the slowest way humanly
possible yeah yeah he's the real cancer
Trump started trumps a guy from [ __ ]
hey he's gay he's a businessman but he's
a Hollywood guy he's they all loved him
he's not he's not [ __ ] anti a he
doesn't give a [ __ ] this is the you
think he wanted to be president would
you rather be would you rather be like a
playboy billionaire that rappers like
and you're on TV or like this vilified
like public figure I don't know man
because then then your opinion is more
than an opinion then you can do what you
want that's a good gig what I think he
just wanted to win that's it yeah I
think he wanted to win the new
presidency but not be the president
before Isis the ego party this is this
is this is a President Obama's fault at
the White House Correspondents Dinner
when he was [ __ ] on Trump and Trump
was like okay like that moment it really
at that moment that you know how they
they are at the White House together
and Trump's now the winner yeah I closed
doors he was appealing that get out of
right out although Oprah and so many
people in the eighties told Trump he
should run the early 90 would telling
Trump he's run for president for 25
years yeah but I think he was responding
to the negative attack I know he was
right but people been saying that for a
long time
who knew yeah I mean it's the same
reason I think that Kanye went nuts
because he's been harboring resentment
from Obama calling him a jackass
I guess those little those little tiny
moment here we go he's just gonna blame
Obama for everything thanks Obama
it was really a nice moment when he left
because the two of the cast members
saying to Sir with love that's the way a
comedy show should handle an exiting
president right just sing a song about
another black guy a city party a that
was in the movie so you might as well
sing it to the black president cuz it
was sung to a black actor right worked
out really beautifully I just think
America needed to get back to their
roots you know yeah oh rich white right
Amin right you know white trash you know
Hicks that's most of it who the
presidents yeah yeah they're like oh we
got to get him back it's like your pores
Oh care about you right all right ready
for you right very right the people
they're hot they thought he did I mean
when he said it he did say it yeah he
said you know yeah but Mary we liked
America treated Trump like they like
like they were all 20 year-old girls and
he was the hot guy and you're like well
he's not gonna lie to me that's what
Trump's appeal is Oh attractive people
is sick and tired of being scolded that
was a huge thing when people were so
yeah sick of being [ __ ] scolded they
were tired of being told that everything
they think is wrong everything they
think that's not a hundred percent PC is
right and he was a reaction to that so
the left who hates him so much Pat
yourselves on the back end dumb
[ __ ] you're the ones that got
him elected that's true it wasn't the
Conservatives that got him elected it
was you guys the Conservatives with Ted
Cruz yeah yeah I agree with that or
somebody else they never would want with
Trump right never yeah and that's a good
point Ted Cruz Mike Pence these guys are
far bigger nightmares they're much
bigger nightmare I always say is it
Trump's fault he was the best candidate
in the Republican Party right now does
that say for the rest everyone being
scolded people were tired of it he was
the guy who was like I don't give a [ __ ]
scold me and they're like I kind of like
that attitude
right hey you know
that's somebody who's at least not
buckling and collapsing to every bit of
you measure to what they say you mean
his only Rosie O'Donnell moment that was
the moment when megyn kelly like you say
all these terrible things about women
and he goes not only Rosie O'Donnell but
it was like there he is it was almost
like of groveling like yeah this guy
brought Bill Clinton's accusers sitting
in the front row
do you know how do you know how terrible
that limo ride home you wanna get your
dick I know I know one time I cheated on
a girl and she caught me and then the
show cheaters came on like three days
later and it was like [ __ ] how did she
catch you you know social media oh
really
yeah in this day and age if you you
can't cheat in this get caught up you
can't cheat yeah are you this you have a
carrier pigeon and you know the main
thing oh yeah you're doing are you doing
Morse code with a [ __ ] that's it right
yeah no yeah yeah because you have to
figure out a regular meeting place to
meet in person quietly and without
anybody else by the way by the way too
not that I condone cheating and you
shouldn't cheat I think it's bad I love
actually talked about this in my snobby
- but here's the thing though you you
have to cheat if you're gonna cheat it's
got to be with somebody that also has
something to lose uh-huh I mean the
problem is you end up cheating with some
right has nothing going on or whatever
and then she's blowing your [ __ ] up
she's gone like talking to your girl
guess where your man is right now and
all sudden you're like what's going on
you got to find some chick with a family
yes have you been cheated on yes how did
you find out I how lonely with the girl
I was with her for like four years
oh [ __ ] I was about I was in that
process of a bat and this is before he
was even doing comedy and I
he was mad at myself because I wasn't
taking care of me I was taking care of
her right you don't mean which is a
turn-off yeah exactly like I'm I'm come
on you can do it rah rah rah she's like
getting raises because of my influence
and all these things and then I wasn't
taking care of me so she woke up one day
I was like I'm doing good what are you
doing right and then I knew - dude she
was cheating on me with cuz she she was
talking about you always listen women
are gonna tell you who they cheatin are
right it's gonna be some [ __ ] like oh
yeah Oh John at work is so funny or it's
gonna be some [ __ ] like that and that's
the dude that she's gonna [ __ ] how long
did she [ __ ] him for before I didn't I
don't know oh you didn't want details
details details and i torture myself
with it it's insanity
yeah I thought um I realized at that
moment I had to get away too because I'm
crazy like that too I feel like I'm I'm
I'm Dreamgirls crazy we attempted to
forgive her or did you want to keep no
no no see this is God why are you
bringing up this wound this is this is
what I find that some women like to do
is they they don't they're it's cowardly
so they don't they're not in love with
you anymore it's not happening but they
still want to be with someone so they
start so they check out their heart
checks out and they start setting up
camp with someone else and then once
that camp is all set up then they go hey
it's not work right but the meanwhile
they're [ __ ] already one foot they
already got another relationship set up
and I'm like and that's what happened to
me
you have their ears and feet and their
[ __ ] over in the other camp so you
found out she told you it immediately
ended the relationship it was gonna end
was done it was already done you know I
mean I he hurt right but I was at work I
had a job at the time and I and I knew
this is how I knew it was ducks I'm
talking to her and she was so cold like
because people the opposite of love is
not hate its indifference yes yeah okay
so when I'm talking to her I
the indifference Oh what was it about
the cheating or something else just just
everything just like she just didn't
want to have anything to do with me you
know that was like [ __ ] so I left my
office and I walked around the block and
I've never talked to her since damn
Wow that was after you already knew
you're having a discussion and you know
she didn't care that you were hurt right
I wanted done it was just and I was like
wow that was it you know what I mean
never talked to her since and then she
married the guy we just before you were
on oh I always dream of like meeting her
with my 29 year old girlfriend and being
like by the way here's workaholics on
DVD enjoy
that's the autograph you wouldn't mind
signed any years ago oh man this was
like over ten years because I and it is
I'm glad it happened because I was like
I didn't know what I wanted to do with
my life I would have liked you told what
you're supposed to do am I supposed to
am I supposed to get a ring and marry
this girl because we were supposedly in
love I was young I regret it I regret
that whole time in my life I just I just
think human beings are adaptable right
now people always say things happen for
a reason and all day I don't believe in
that [ __ ]
I believe that like the reason why we
can live in Minnesota and we can live in
Phoenix you know is because that's how
we that's what we do we can live in hot
places cold places we deal with [ __ ]
yeah so it's just like how we come out
the other side that's what makes us who
we are
and I do and you could look back you can
have regrets it regrets that what
inspire you to be better in whatever
you're doing now so those people that
say don't have regrets no no you have if
you have some regrets make sure you
don't repeat the same mistake